to us one piece fans the straw hats are
like one big family not just to each
other but to us too however what kind of
illustrious or not so illustrious
families did they come from that's
exactly what we'll be exploring today as
I look into each straw Hat's family tree
I'm talking Luffy's Mom zoro's confirmed
parents and much more we are going to
break down everything we know about
their families as well as discussing a
few persistent and compelling theories
so make sure to stick around until the
very end now if you do enjoy these one
piece videos on the channel and you'd
like to see more you know what to do
smash that like button if you haven't
already join the knock up by subscribing
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications we are so very
close to hitting that amazing Milestone
of 2 million subscribers here on the
channel so every subscription counts and
now without further Ado let's jump into
the family trees spoilers and all it
seems more than fitting to start with
Luffy as he has not only a very
interesting family tree but also a bunch
to get through starting with his dad
Monkey D Dragon Luffy's relationship
with dragon is still shrouded in mystery
and many details about their connection
have yet to be revealed in the manga
anime Monkey D dragon is Luffy's father
and the leader of the Revolutionary Army
a group that opposes the world
government Luffy and dragon have not had
Direct interactions or reunions in the
series Luffy himself was unaware of
dragon's identity for a significant
portion of the story The Narrative has
intentionally kept details about
dragon's past and motivations
undisclosed contributing to the Intrigue
surrounding the character it's clear
that dragon has his own agenda and is
involved in challenging the oppressive
World Government despite being family up
until now the contract in paths and
seeming lack of personal connection
between Luffy and dragon added a
complexity and mystery to their
relationship fans eagerly awaited
developments that would shed more light
on the connection between Luffy and his
enigmatic father Monkey D Dragon
fortunately we did get some big reveals
recently showing why Dragon abandoned
Luffy and how he truly feels about him
during chapter 1,11 Kuma confronted
Dragon saying you seem extremely
familiar with this particular nation and
I couldn't help but notice you traveling
to a little village at the edge of the
country and watching a particular young
lad so even before before Dragon helped
Luffy escape from smoker it's clear that
he cared enough about him to go back and
visit him every so often but then why
why didn't he reveal himself to Luffy
well he answers that by saying to Kuma
keep going if you want to see me killed
children are a vulnerability for any
parent end quote in other words Dragon
cares too much about Luffy someone could
take advantage of that if they for
instance kidnapped Luffy and used him to
get to dragon dragon pretty much admits
that if it came to him or Luffy he would
give his life so when Luffy was still
weak did his best to keep his distance
so no one would Target Luffy considering
that many took Dragon for a dead beat
dad for the majority of the series this
was a game changing reveal into his true
thoughts and motivations next we have
Luffy's legendary grandfather Monkey D
GARP GARP is Luffy's grandfather and a
vice admiral in the Marines despite
their familial connection their
relationship is characterized by a
unique blend of loving conflict GARP
like his grandson is known for a strong
sense of freedom and is famous for
turning down the position of Admiral
multiple times due to his his desire to
live life on his own terms This Love For
Freedom seems to have been passed down
to Luffy GARP deeply cares for Luffy but
their conflicting ideals and roles in
the world create tension rather than
Dragon GARP was the one who raised Luffy
by leaving Luffy with GARP it allowed
Luffy to grow up away from the influence
of the dangerous world of pirates and
revolutionaries associated with dragon
but then of course shranks happened
despite being a marine GARP loves his
grandson and has shown moments of pride
in Luffy's achievements however they're
conflicting allegiances gar being a high
ranking marine and Luffy being a pirate
create a complex Dynamic GARP is torn
between his duty as a marine and his
love for his grandson and this conflict
is evident in several instances
throughout the series for instance Garf
couldn't bring himself to capture or
kill Luffy during the Paramount war and
even had to be restrained by sokku after
Ace was killed by sakazuki Otherwise
GARP would have been trying to kill
sakazuki rather than Luffy so although
he is a marine and he is torn at times
to me it's still pretty obvious that the
grandpa side was always stronger we have
to look at Luffy's sworn Brothers Ace
and Sabo too Monkey D Luffy's
relationship with porcas d Ace is one of
the most emotionally charged and
impactful aspects of the onepiece series
Ace is Luffy's adopted brother and a
significant figure in Luffy's life
contributing greatly to the emotional
depth of the narrative I mean Ace's
death at Marine Ford has to be one of
the most heartbreaking and memorable
moments in the entire series Luffy and
Ace share a bond that goes beyond blood
relation Ace whose real name is gold D
Ace is the son of pying Goldie Roger
Luffy unaware of this connection for
much of their early lives simply
considers Ace to be brother they share a
common dream of becoming Pirates and
sailing the seas in search of the
legendary treasure one piece their
relationship is characterized by deep
love loyalty and mutual respect Luffy
admires Ace for his strength
Independence and big Bress Ace in turn
cares deeply for Luffy often acting as a
big brother figure who is ready to
sacrifice pretty much everything for
Luffy's wellbeing just think once more
about the heartbreaking sacrifice of
marine Ford where he took sakazuki
deadly punch so Luffy wouldn't have to
but let's take a closer look at this
pivotal moment in their relationship
which occurs during the Marine Ford AR
Ace is captured by the Marines and
sentenced to execution Luffy driven by
an intense desire to save his brother
launches a daring rescue mission leading
to one of the most emotionally charged
and tragic events in the series AC's
death profoundly impacts Luffy leading
to a significant shift in his character
AC's passing becomes a driving force for
Luffy's Journey reinforcing his
commitment to become the pirate king and
protecting those he cares about Luffy's
relationship with Sabo is another
emotionally significant aspect of the
one piece series Sabo is also like a
brother to Luffy Luffy along with Sabu
and Ace formed a strong bond during
their shared childhood in the great
terminal of Windmill Village despite
facing difficult circumstances the trio
dreamed of becoming Pirates and sailing
the Seas together however tragedy struck
when Sabo seemingly died in an incident
leaving a lasting impact on both Luffy
and Ace the Revelation that Sabo is
Alive and Well is a significant moment
in the series in direct contrast to the
loss of brother Ace the reunion between
Luffy and brother Sabo is filled with
positive emotions sabo's return also
plays a pivotal role in the dress Rosa
Arc where he becomes a key Ally Al in
Luffy's Quest and helps him navigate the
challenges posed by the donot Pirates
you got to love to see the brothers
shared commitment to their dreams and
their willingness to support each other
in the face of adversity and although
some fans felt cheated by the Sabo
reveal since it arguably felt like Sabo
came from nowhere and was wedged into
the well-established brother Ace and
Luffy Dynamic I'm still glad that Luffy
gained a brother he thought he'd lost
after the tragic loss of a big bro Ace
and the fact that Sabo is cool a
revolutionary and the successor of Ace's
flame fruit makes me even happier about
his inclusion into the story after all
how could we Imagine One Piece without
thinking of the flame Emperor these days
now the lingering question in regard to
Luffy's family tree is of course that of
who is Luffy's mother well of course we
don't have a confirmed answer for that
but that hasn't stopped people from
speculating and one of the most
persistent ones as crazy as it sounds at
first glance is that crocodile is
actually a woman who was turned into a
man with ivanov's huu no me and that
would be the secret weak Ness that
Ivanov uses to Blackmail crocodile in
chapter 540 crocodile used to be a woman
and not only that he is literally
Luffy's mother this Theory got even more
attention when during the liveaction
Netflix adaptation of one piece we see a
woman with serious bling around her neck
getting screen time during Roger's
execution and people are speculating
it's crocodile before his transformation
on top of that the Luffy actor for
Netflix's one piece let it slip in an
interview that crocodile was in this
season and then think of how crocodile
has come back into relev because of
cross Guild lately in the manga so yeah
either way it seems like we're going to
find out what that secret is that Ivanka
was talking about and this theory is
surprisingly looking less Crazy by the
day up next let's look at zoro's Family
Tree despite being a descendant of the
shimoi family Zoro appears to be utterly
clueless of his connection to it and the
people he has encountered throughout his
life it is unknown what if any
relationship he had with his father and
mother sword God shimoi ryuma the fame
swordsman of wano is zoro's ancestor
fans may recall ryuma from the Thriller
barkar in which it was revealed that
Moria had taken the fame Samurai's body
and reanimated it with Brooks's Shadow
Duma was a renowned Warrior who was
revered as the god of the blade in his
day it hasn't been confirmed exactly
what year he lived however it is
possible that he lived during the void
Century Ruma once slay a large dragon in
wano earning him a high reputation and
that was only one of swordsman ruma's
remarkable accomplishments ruma's Clan
the shotski kept their bloodline going
and they remained active in the plot of
One Piece Zoro met ryuma by chance
during the Thriller bark Arc and it
wasn't until wano that it was revealed
that Zoro and Zuma had a lot of
similarities for starters their combat
techniques are remarkably similar
furthermore hyogoro stated on orig
gashima that ryuma like Zoro was a
oneeyed samurai Zoro doesn't just share
connection with shimoi Ruma though the
fact that Zoro resembled shimoi ushimaru
was revealed in the wano country Arc as
well however no further Insight was
provided to fans until the SPs corner of
volume 105 of the manga came out UDA
presents a full family tree of NOA Zoro
in it and it has now been verified that
Zoro shares blood with ushimaru a ship
departed wano illegally and landed in
the East blue over 50 years ago shimoi
kosaburo a famed swordsmith from wano
was aboard this ship according to the
manga however he was not the only shimoi
Clan member on the ship shimoi furo was
also aboard the ship according to the
SBS this lady is none other than zoro's
grandmother she is also the elder sister
of shimoi ushimaru whom Zoro resembles
so much when kosaburo arrived in East
blue he found his own Community shimoi
Village there he also built a dojo which
was eventually taken over by his son
shimoi koshiro meanwhile zoro's
grandmother furo mared a swordsman in
the village named ranoa pin Zoro which
is where the family name ranoa comes
from the name was subsequently handed
down through the family and finally
ended up with Zoro zoro's family tree
goes on to reveal that shimoi fiko and
ranoa penzo had a child and they named
him roronoa arashi given that both sides
of his family had Swordsmen it may be
assumed that arashi zoro's father was
also a skilled swordsman what fans do
know about arashi is that he perished in
an unknown fight against Pirates in the
East blue at an unknown period however
before he died arashi married a lady
named Tara Oda like with arashi has not
disclosed much about Tara Oda just
describes her as the daughter of
thieving Bandits and we know that terara
means Earth in several languages perhaps
Zoro gets his green like grass hair
color from her arashi and terara
obviously had the child we know as ronoa
Zoro Tara became critically ill and died
as a result of her sickness so with both
of his parents supposedly dead Zoro was
left an orphan it is unknown whether
Tara died soon after giving birth or
whether she nurtured Zoro till a
particular point in time Zoro then went
on to learn the way of the blade in the
village of shimoi doo where he met his
cousin quina it's unclear whether Zoro
is aware that Kina and he are biological
relatives regardless fans now have a
complete family tree for ranoa Zoro and
it is an understatement to say that Zoro
2 has an interesting past in origin and
on personally sure that Oda won't leave
the story of his parents as footnotes in
an SPS I'm sure we'll come back to his
father at least at some point in the
story I've even discussed theories on
the channel That zoro's father may not
be dead at all perhaps arashi faked his
death or pulled aabo and got amnesia and
doesn't know he is arashi I mean think
about it are we really meant to believe
that the descendant of Sword God Ruma
and another swordsman family whose
Silhouettes look a lot like mihawk mind
you was killed in a random battle
against unnamed Pirates nah there has to
be more to as mentioned I've discussed
both how the Silhouettes look like
mihawk before although I think we can
all agree mihawk being zoro's father
would be a bit much still there's no
reason they cannot be related in some
other way and aside from that I also
mentioned the now less talked about but
once popular theory that zoro's father
could be greenbull this would assume
that arashi didn't physically die in the
battle against Pirates just his identity
Wesley becoming dread pirate Robert
style this Theory doesn't seem as crazy
when you think about all the parallels
between greenbull and Zoro they were
both introduced while fasting and Zoro
broke his fast when a girl fed him while
green bull said he might break his fast
if a girl fed him they both got green
hair and are predominantly associated
with the color of green Sanji calls Zoro
a moss head and in his Forest human form
greenbull literally looks like he has a
moss head they both suck at directions
and love boo and the list goes on as
outlined in my zoro's father video but
one last and big detail mention is that
Zoro and zoro's Father's ancestor
ushimaru wore green Bulls on his clothes
so it could be a meaningful symbol
passed on in the family and thus a
Admiral name for zoro's father again not
saying any of these theories are 100%
true just briefly mentioning some
interesting and hard to ignore theories
moving on let's look at Nami we don't
know who nami's real parents are or
where she came from in the first place
what we do know is that Nami was
discovered by nojo when they were both
children and that the two were later
discovered by belmir who took them in
and eventually cared for them let's take
a look at her relationship with belir
nami was an orphan living in kocasi
Village when belir discovered her belir
despite being a Marine showed compassion
and took Nami and noo in as her own
daughters she provided them with love
care and a sense of family in an
environment where they had previously
lacked stability bm's relationship with
nami is that of a mother and daughter
Bel meir's love for Nami is evident in
her actions as she worked hard to
provide for and protect Nami and nojo
her decision to adopt them and give them
a chance at a better life reflects her
selflessness and maternal instincts the
most heart-wrenching moment in their
relationship occurs during the arlong
park Ark where arlong an Infamous
Fishman pirate the demands a substantial
amount of money from nami's adoptive
mother in a heartbreaking turn of events
belmir sacrifices herself to save her
daughters refusing to let arlong harm
them but perhaps more importantly she
sacrifices herself because she cannot
even for a moment allow herself to not
acknowledge the two as her daughters
even if it means her life the event
leaves a lasting impact on NAMI shaping
her character and influencing her
motivations nami's pursuit of wealth and
navigation skills which she uses to
create mass for arlong are initially a
means to free her Village from arlong's
control however after the village is
freed she continues to use her skills in
order to support the straw hats and in
order to chase her dream of creating a
complete map of the world the emotional
Resonance of nami's character is deeply
tied to her relationship with belir the
sacrifice and love that belmir displayed
became a driving force behind nami's
determination and her eventual joining
of the straw hats the memory of belmir
continues to influence nami's actions
and it serves as a powerful reminder of
the importance of family and the impact
of selfless acts of love and sacrifice
then there's noo noo is several years
older than Nami and took on a nurturing
and protective role after the death of
belmir she became a source of strength
and support for Nami during challenging
times especially in the aftermath of
arlong's occupation of kocasi Village
despite the hardships they fac noo
remained a constant stabilizing presence
in nami's life the depth of their bond
is evident in the arlong park Arc where
nami's painful pass is revealed and
Niko's role as a supportive sister
becomes even more pronounced noo
understand standing and empathy
contribute to nami's emotional healing
and resilience noo not only provides
Comfort but also encourages Nami to
pursue her dreams and find happiness
beyond the traumas of her past after
Nami joins the straw hats nojo remains
in kocasi Village continuing her life
there however their connection remains
strong and noo serves as a reminder of
nami's roots and the love they shared as
a family throughout the series nami's
relationship with nojo is a testament to
enduring power of familial bonds even
when faced with adversity noj's
unwavering support has undoubtedly
played a crucial role in shaping the
Nami we know today the strong and
determined Navigator of the straw hat
crew next up let's look at usopp's
Family treat usopp's father is yaso yaso
is a sharpshooter in the red-hair
Pirates and his absence from Uso's life
has played a significant role in shaping
Uso's character and dreams yaso left his
family including Usopp when the latter
was very young to pursue his adventures
as a pirate under the command of
redhaired Shanks this departure had a
profound impact on USA as he grew up
idolizing his father's sense of
adventure and the Romanticism of a
pirate's life however Usopp also
grappled with a longing for zaps and
father despite the physical distance
yaso influence on usopp's dreams is
unmistakable Usopp aspires to become a
brave Warrior of the sea and a great
sniper much like his father the story
suggests that Usopp inherited his
exceptional Marksmanship skills from
yaso making their connection even more
significant the opportunity for a
reunion between yaso and Uso is
anticipated by fans as it could provide
closure and further character
development for Usopp it's clear that
Uso Harbors both admiration and a sense
of longing for his father and meeting
yaso again could potentially offer an
important emotional resolution for
usopp's character Arc then there's
usopp's mother banina she was a kind and
supportive mother who deeply cared for
Usopp her impact on usopp's character is
a key factor in his dream of becoming a
brave Warrior of the sea and a great
Storyteller tragically usopp's mom Falls
ill and passes away leaving Usopp an
orphan at a young age on her deathbed
even though she tells Usopp to stop
being stupid and that his father is not
coming back for them she still says
she's proud she married yaso usopp's mom
told him to become a brave man like his
father and so it's probable that usopp's
dream of becoming a great warrior of the
sea is further motivated by his mother
just like his father motivates him his
mother's dying wish likely serves as a
source of inspiration for Usopp
motivating him further to pursue his
dreams moving on to sanji's family treat
Sanji has had a troubled relationship
with his family the VIN smoke family
especially with the men of the family
their Regal pride and single-minded
concentration on Power and combat CL
with his personal goals and Love of
Cooking but there's much more to unpack
here starting with his father Vince
smoke judge sanji's relationship with
his father Vince smoke judge is a
complex and strained one judge is the
head of the Vince smoke family a
powerful and technologically advanced
family of genetically modified
superhuman assassins Sanji is the third
son of Judge and was born without the
enhanced physical abilities and combat
skills that characterize his siblings
we'll get into why he was born that way
later From sanji's perspective his
relationship with judge is marked by
emotional and physical abuse Sanji was
treated as an outcast within the Vince
smoke family due to his perceived
weakness and judge considered him a
failure compared to his genetically
modified siblings this treatment left
deep scars on sanji's self-esteem and
contributed to his desire to escape the
clutches of his family and pursue a
different path in life judge on the
other hand sees Sanji as a
disappointment and as a disgrace to the
Vince smoke name he views emotions and
compassion as weaknesses traits that he
believes hinder the strength and success
of the VIN smoke family jud's strict and
cold approach to Parenting stands in St
contrast to Sanji values particularly
his deep respect for women and his
aversion to violence against those he
perceives as weaker the climax of their
strain relationship occurs during the
hul cake Island Ark where Sanji
confronts his family to protect his
friends particularly his captain Monkey
D Luffy the ark delves deeper into
sanji's past and explores the
psychological and emotional trauma he
endured within the Vince smoke family
then there is his mother Vince smok Sora
Sora was the wife of Vince smoke judge
and the mother of Sanji and his siblings
unlike judge Sora was a kind and
compassionate woman who dis approved of
the cruel and inhumane experiments
conducted on her children which aimed to
enhance their physical in combat
abilities during the events of hul cake
Island it is revealed that Sora had a
significant impact on sanji's
development she secretly acted against
judge's plans for Sanji arranging for
his emotions and compassion to remain
intact sora's actions preserved sanji's
humanity and kindness making him the
compassionate and chivalrous person he
is known to be sanji's love for cooking
and his respect for women are definitely
tied to his kind mother in fact she
helped spark his Love of Cooking when he
messed up a DI that he took to her and
she called it yummy he was overjoyed and
that inspired him to keep practicing
cooking even when he was imprisoned and
kept in an Iron Mask sora's influence on
sanji's character is one of the more
emotionally impactful elements of the
narrative and especially of sanji's
backstory showcasing the positive impact
a mother's love and values can have even
in the face of insane levels of
adversity and we're talking your
brothers always beating you up and your
father turning you into the Man in the
Iron Mask levels of adversity just to be
clear sanji's sister of insmoke is the
only sibling among the VIN smoke
children who showed Sanji kindness and
empathy during their childhood rayu
being the eldest of the vinsmoke
siblings seemed to have a more
compassionate nature compared to her
brothers unlike the rest of the family
she didn't Harbor contempt for Sanji and
was willing to help him when he faced
adversity Ru in many instances secretly
aided Sanji by providing him with food
and expressing concern for his
well-being during the hake island arc
her complex relationship with Sanji is
further explored it is revealed that she
released Sanji from prison and helped
him Escape his horrible Vince smoke
existence however her actions are not
purely unselfish when she was nice to
Sanji it was in secret while she is
still loyal to the VIN smoke family and
carries out their orders publicly
despite her conflicted loyalties she
maintains a level of respect and
understanding for Sanji she recognized
his kindness and the differences between
him and the rest of the insmoke siblings
their interactions particularly during
the hul cake island arc delve deeper
into the nuances of their relationship
and the internal conflicts faced by Ru
saji's relationship with his brother
others ichii niiji and yonji is marked
by deep-seated conflict and a stark
contrast in values the Vince smoke
siblings were genetically modified by
their father as mentioned judge to
become superhuman assassins devoid of
emotions and condition for combat
prowess ichii nii and yonji view Sanji
with disdain due to his lack of enhanced
physical abilities and his refusal to
conform to the VIN smoke family's
ruthless ideology at least at first they
see him as a failure a sentiment
fostered by their father's belief that
strength and power are the only measures
of worth sajji detests his brothers and
the Vince spoke family for their cruelty
and lack of empathy his clashes with his
brothers highlight the Stark difference
in their principles Sanji values
compassion chivalry and respect for
women which are traits he retained due
to the intervention of his mother Sora
who opposed judges values and
modifications the animosity between
Sanji and his brothers reaches another
Peak during the hul cake island arc
where their conflicting ideologies come
to the Forefront again sanji's refusal
to conform to the Vince smoke way of
life and his emotional attachment to his
friends particularly the straw hats
intensify the friction at times but when
the big mom Pirates betray the VIN
smokes we do see them working together
on the same side which allows for the
possibility of them being on the same
side again in the future despite their
differences at the end of the day
despite the tragic backstory we can say
sanji's relationship with his siblings
is simply one of hatred as we saw during
the hake island arc it's more
complicated than that and just as Sanji
came to their rescue they also helped
Sanji and Luffy Escape next up let's
look at Chopper's family treat Chopper's
biological family is a herd of r
reindeer that abandon him because he's
different initially rejected because of
his blue nose he is abandoned further
after consuming the hitoo no meat which
gave him two un reindeer like humanoid
forms he finally crossed paths with them
again during his time with hiriluk when
he was beaten up by them his left antler
was shattered Chopper's relationship
with Dr hiriluk is a heartwarming and
significant aspect of Chopper's
character development huk is a quack
doctor living in the drum Island Kingdom
an choin initially meets him when he's
in need of medical help Dr huk is an
eccentric and compassionate character
who lives by the philosophy that a
person can be cured with love and
laughter despite his unconventional
methods he is genuinely caring and
becomes a mentor and a father figure to
Chopper his positive influence on
Chopper goes beyond just medical
knowledge he teaches Chopper valuable
life lessons about the importance of
dreams self-worth and the ability to
make a difference Chopper's admiration
for the doctor is evident in how the
doctor's philosophy shapes Chopper's
outlook on life Hook's dream of curing
any disease with a cherry blossom
Miracle also becomes a guiding force for
Chopper the cherry blossom symbolic of
Hook's hope and love hold deep
significance for Chopper and represent
the embodiment of his mentor Spirit
tragically Dr Hook's life is cut short
but his legacy lives on through Chopper
Hook's final moments and his speech
deeply impact Chopper motivating him to
fulfill Hook's dream and become a great
doctor then there was of course his
adopted mother Dr Kura Chopper's
relationship with Dr Kura is another
significant informative Connection in
his life choer first meets the doctor on
drum Island where she serves serves as a
doctor and is renowned for her medical
skills initially Dr Kura seems Stern and
demanding but her tough exterior hides a
caring and wise nature Kura takes
Chopper under her wing and becomes his
mentor after the passing of hiriluk
despite her Gruff demeanor she imparts
valuable medical knowledge to Chopper
helping him grow into a skilled and
compassionate doctor under her guidance
Chopper not only hones his medical
abilities but also learns about the
responsibilities that come with being a
doctor one of the key moments in their
relationship is when Chopper decides to
leave drum Island and join the straw
head Pirates Dr Kura while initially
appearing unsupportive ultimately gives
Chopper her approval and encourages him
to pursue his dreams this moment
reflects her belief in Chopper's
potential and her acknowledgement of his
growth their bond also adds a touch of
humor to the series as Dr ca's eccentric
personality and Chopper's reactions to
are antics create entertaining
interactions despite the age and
personality differences there is a
mutual respect and affection between
them Dr ca's influence on Chopper
extends Beyond medicine she teaches him
about life determination and the
importance of pursuing one's dream her
role as a mentor and guide plays a
crucial part in Chopper's character
development contributing to his
self-confidence and sense of purpose
moving on next we have niiko Robin's
family treat niik Olia is Robin's mother
and their connection is deeply
intertwined with the larger Narrative of
the series particularly the history and
mystery surrounding the true history and
the void Century Robin's childhood was
marked by tragedy when her mother Nico
Olia left their home to pursue
archaeological research ultimately
leading to her involvement with the
mysterious and forbidden pomog the World
Government branded the poneglyphs as
dangerous and Robin's mother became a
fugitive this decision had severe
consequences for the island of Ohara as
the government executed the infamous
Buster call destroying the island and
most of its inhabitants both Robin and
Olia were there at the time ulia's
concern was Robin she was very proud of
her daughter that she had learned to
read the poneglyphs she loved her but
also had to be true to herself and
decided to sacrifice her life in the
hopes that knowledge of the past would
be passed on to the next Generation it
was her way of not giving up on the
future although Robin didn't understand
at the time Olia reassured her that she
will understand someday before she told
Saul to leave and take her daughter to
safety Olia was also very touched that
Robin called her mother and thanked her
for it her final wish was for Robin to
live despite the physical separation
ulia's Legacy significantly influences
Robin's life Robin inherits her mother's
passion for archaeology and the
deciphering of the Pags the Deep
connection to the mysteries of the Void
century and the true history becomes a
driving force for Robin leading her to
seek the knowledge that her mother
pursued at the cost of her own life back
when her mother Olia along with other
archaeologists embarked on a six-year
expedition to investigate the poneglyph
2-year-old Robin was left in the care of
her brother's wife Roi although she was
sorry to have to leave Robin it was
something she felt she had to do Roi
despised Robin and abused her treating
her like nothing more than a slave
thankfully Uncle oron would defend Robin
his sister's child so I guess it could
have been worse Robin had a father as
well but she never met him and his name
is unknown however when Olia was
boarding her ship to leave for the
Expedition she was told that and I quote
if you can't leave your child then don't
come we'll fulfill your husband's wishes
end quote so clearly this suggests that
her father was also an important scholar
and the others wanted to fulfill his
wishes Olia responded though that she is
a scholar of Ohara and cannot abandon
the will of those who came before she
planned to come home when the mystery
was solved but things didn't work out so
perfectly as we know next up we have
Frankie and his family tree Frankie is
the son of pirates who have not been
named his parents appear to have been
unimpressed with his childhood Creations
as they were the reason he was dumped
into the sea at the age of 10 Frankie
seemed to detest them for it and that's
why when Odin asked him about joining
Roger's crew he replied a pirate no way
I just got abandoned by Pirates unquote
despite not being blood relatives the
whole Frankie family was created by Him
to care for water 7's quote unquote
failures and rejects such as zomi the
members of the group are extremely close
referring to each other and others on
good terms with them as sister and
brother they water s's Misfits like
people who aspired to work for iceberg
in the gal La Corporation but failed the
entrance exam to become ships as a
result they had little choice but to
resort to Frankie who also feels himself
to be a failure and of course we got to
mention Master ship right Tom the mentor
who became like a father figure to him
after his pirate parents abandoned him
Tom was none other than the man who
could proudly claim that he built pirate
king Goldie Rogers ship so definitely a
good Mentor for Luffy shipright Tom
praised Frankie for his ingenious
Creations it's clear these two meant a
lot to each other Tom was going to be
pardon after building the puffing Tom
for previously building Roger ship but
after spand them used Frankie's battle
Frankies to attack water 7even Tom
decided to take responsibility for
Frankie's Creations he used his pardon
to save Frankie and thus still had to
pay for his own crimes whether those
should have been crimes in the first
place is another story he was being
escorted by his own sea train to any's
Lobby Frankie actually tried to stop the
train but was run over he had to become
a cyborg because of the injuries he
suffered from trying to save Tom the man
who saved him Tom helped Inspire
Frankie's dream of building a ship that
would proudly sail over uncharted waters
all the way to the ends of the world and
he instilled in him the lesson that a
ship right must be out of his Creations
even if others use them for evil moving
on to the family tree of Brooke the
members of Brook's biological family are
unknown but the closest thing we know he
had to a family were the rumar Pirates
Brook's relationship with the rumar
Pirates is a deeply emotional and
significant aspect of his character
backstory the rumar Pirates were a group
of musical Pirates and Brooke was a
musician and second captain the rumar
Pirates including Brooke shared a strong
bond forged their love of Music
adventure and camaraderie they traveled
the grand line together facing the
challenges of the sea while spreading
Joy through their music tragedy struck
the rumar Pirates during their Journey
when they encountered the deadly plague
as the crew succumb to the illness one
by one they fac The Dilemma of what to
do next Captain yorki and the other
infected were left behind and they hoped
to exit the grand line meanwhile Brooke
and the healthy continued forward sadly
everyone except Brooke who survived
because of the revive revive fruit met
their end after a battle with Pirates
Who used poisoned weapons not going to
lie poisoned weapons is a good idea for
a pirate crew but anyways before the
poison finished off the crew they sang
One Last Time recording it with a tone
dial which Brooke planned to take to
laboon after the death of the rumar
Pirates Brooke continued on and
eventually met the straw hat Pirates he
joined the crew bringing his musical
talents and the memories of his former
crew mates with him and now he still
plans to keep their wishes going by
returning the right way from the grand
line and meeting laboon again and of
course laboon the whale is the closest
thing to family that Brook still has
from his past life a lonely laboon
actually started following the rumar
Pirates after he was separated from his
whale family and thus they became his
new family they cheered up the lonely
whale with music Brooke is actually the
one who named him laboon when they
entered the grand line they were
surprised to find the laboon had
followed them when they had to part ways
the crew promised that they would return
after traveling all the way around the
grand line and laboon waited and waited
eventually he couldn't take it anymore
and started slamming into reverse
Mountain hoping to destroy it and that
his friends would be on the other side
waiting for him it's one of the most
touching aspects of One Piece no doubt
and I can't wait for that Brooke and
laboon reunion next up is jimbe and his
family treat Jim Ba's real family is
unknown for now but we do know he grew
up as an orphan and that he grew up with
his sworn brother Fisher tiger jinbe's
relationship with Fisher tiger is rooted
in their shared history as members of
the sun Pirates a Fishman crew that
fought against oppression and
discrimination Fisher tiger was a legend
and was the captain of the sun Pirates
and jimbe served as his first mate
Fisher tiger was a formidable and
charismatic leader who vly opposed the
mistreatment of fishermen and merfolk he
was known for his uncompromising stance
against slavery and discrimination and
his actions were driven by a desire for
freedom and equality under Fisher
Tiger's leadership the sun Pirates
fought against the world Nobles who were
notorious for their oppressive treatment
of fishmen jimbe deeply respected Fisher
tiger and admired his commitment to
Justice Fisher Tiger's influence on
jimbe was profound shaping jinbe's own
principles and convictions their time
together as Sun Pirates created a strong
bond between them and jimbe carried
Fisher Tiger's ideals with him even
after Tiger's death the final and bonus
TRW head family treat to look at is
vivies though not a member who joins the
crew on the Big Adventures she is
considered a part of the crew by the cor
raw hat so we'll add her here to the
list viv's relationship with her father
king cobra is characterized by love Duty
and the responsibilities that come with
being royalty king cobra was the man who
ruled over alabasta and Vivy was his
beloved daughter and Princess throughout
the alabasta arc it becomes evident that
Vivie cares deeply for her father and
the feeling is reciprocated by King
Cobra despite the political turmoil and
conspiracies that threaten disability of
alabasta their familial bonds remain
strong king cobra is shown to be a wise
caring ruler concerned for the welfare
of both his daughter and his kingdom as
the conflict in alabas intensifies Vivie
faces the difficult task of balancing
her Duty as a princess with her desire
to save her country king cobra
understands the challenges she faces and
appreciates her courage and
determination he acknowledges viv's
strength and commitment to alasta when
Vivie chooses to remain in her kingdom
to rebuild and govern her decision is a
testament to her loyalty to her people
and her commitment to carrying on in her
Father's Footsteps king cobra is proud
of his daughter's choices and trusts
ala's future in her capable hands Queen
TT viv's mom died many years before the
present storyline because of this we
don't know much about the relationship
she had with Vivie but Vivy definitely
gets her looks from her we also recently
found out about the very important
nefari D Lily Lily who seems like yet
another Vivy lookalike was the queen
during the void Century 800 years ago
and one of the 20 monarchs credited with
founding the world government however
they didn't actually know she was a d
unlike the others she didn't choose to
become a Celestial Dragon and go to
marija but she never made it home as
Cobra points out before the elders her
little brother took the throne instead
we recently found out that Lily made a
mistake or at least the world government
thought it was a big mistake and it is
thanks to her that the poneglyphs were
scattered across the world once Cobra
finds out about this and reveals that
her letter was signed with a d emu
immediately goes to eliminate him and he
does die despite Sabo trying to save him
so it makes sense that someone in viv's
family tree would do what Lily did and
it turns out that Vivy being a just
ruler and an ally to the straw hats is
following in her footsteps 800 years
later and those are the family treat
trees of all the straw hats with all the
information we have at this current
moment and of course some fun theories
thrown in there as well if you want
another big one piece video to check out
after this one then you don't want to
miss my hourlong video on the legend
Shanks if you did enjoy this video and
you like to see more one piece videos on
the channel make sure to let us know by
Smashing that like button if you haven't
already make this the video you join the
knock them up by subscribing and hitting
that notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates
you'd also be helping us reach that
insane goal of 2 million subscribers
thanks again and I'll see you in the
next one